now in part two of my interview with a
country music icon and Jennifer Aniston
I had to know all that jolly dazzle how
it found its way to dumpling when they
approached you about having a movie with
like your songs honored were you for
this opportunity very honored yeah when
they asked if I would write some
additional music for it I was more than
happy to do this my it looks like the
Miss America pageant out there gin plays
a former beauty queen and dumpling who's
plus-size daughter in terms of pageant
what I throw at your Dolly Parton City
Gym Jennifer Aniston is my friend I'm
dying on the inside that's it crying I'm
just it's just been pinch me pinch me
exciting the soundtrack album is out now
and listen to Jen singing backup to
dolly on the song push and pull
[Music]
but she did a good job they laughed she
wished and walked in there actually does
everything else like a real pro she put
those headphones on and she was a little
nervous that good tale but we had but I
sang through it and then got my voice
and I literally had barely I couldn't
even have a squeak come out well and
then when we finished I remember I just
burst into tears
we got a little break out there on your
forehead would you think about the
accident I thought she did great and I
told her that I went to see it with her
and I was sitting right by her and I was
really impressed and I knew she worried
about it because she hadn't she didn't
know she needed to hear it from somebody
but knew yeah so I leave you and I said
accents great it's a great job and she
said when Dahlia brews you're good now
Jen's a native New Yorker she hired a
dialect coach to help her perfect that
southern accent this movie is so cute
dumpling premieres Friday on Netflix
[Music]